hi I'm Kate Harris and I am a mobile
product manager that focuses on Android
at the New York Times them with hi I'm
Ferris ear I work on our Android app I'm
a designer we were actually on Android
pretty early our first appt debuted in
2010 but I think we we like many other
publishers and developers were very
rushed just to get something out there
and we took what we knew which was iOS
at the time and tried to make it work on
Android when Google came out with the
design principles with Android 4.3
decided that that was the right time to
completely rehal what we had and embrace
the new principles and relaunch our app
in response we recommitted to Android
I'd say yeah and I think I think our
goal was to make it more intuitive for
Android users and I think I think that
worked after a lot of work in September
we were able to relaunch our phone app
and then quickly after in December we
launched our responsive app which took
our phone app and scaled it up so it
looked great on 7-inch tablets and
10-inch tablets and so this is what our
old article looked like and here's our
new article and fair can actually tap
into the lead photo and enter slideshow
so it's a much more interactive article
representation you know just by looking
at our list of articles in our old app
which ferrer is holding on the left and
comparing it with our new and improved
list of articles on the right you can
see visually just how striking the
differences are well it was interesting
having those constraints in place
actually helped us focus and push our
ideas a little further kind of thinking
differently than we would have if we
just had blue skies so it was good to
have those suggestions or guidelines
and and be able to think about how to
make it our own app within those and I
think they helped a lot with usability
you know android android users are
familiar with you know these patterns
and we were able to work them in still
make them our own another great thing
about the redesign was the way we used
image varieties and kind of just
optimized for the device that the user
is on so if you look at the tablet we
have these big beautiful images that
show off our photography and then if you
look at it on the phone we take into
consideration you know conserving data
and performance so we load a smaller
image there I think how we made this app
feel like the New York Times had had a
lot to do with typography so we were
able to integrate you know our custom
typefaces and our colors and the way
that we we mix typefaces together is
very New York it makes it feel like the
New York Times one thing that's great
about the google play store is it allows
us to move quicker with new releases so
now we're actually launching features on
android first before we roll them out on
our other platforms some of the features
that have debuted first on android our
text to speech and also comments was
rolled out on android and it's something
that we're actively working on on our
other platforms because our users were
so engaged with the with the content so
we're continually working to improve the
app last week we just released search
which is very exciting users can search
locally on the device and also search
from the website we've seen a lot
incredible growth actually since we
relaunch the phone app our monthly
unique users have gone up over two
hundred percent and since we relaunched
or actually launched the responsive app
spanning two tablet our tablet numbers
have increased by five hundred percent